[Music]
real life wizards chess was way cooler
than we'd expect thanks to some radio
controlled super-sized pieces that was
really exciting because i got to sit on
the horse i remember really enjoying
that fox dumbledore's phoenix wasn't cgi
or a real bird disguised as the mythical
creature it was an incredibly built
puppet that looked and felt so real that
richard harris initially thought it was
alive taking advantage of the moment the
animatronics controllers continued to
fool harris making the bird move around
and behave like well a bird pretty good
huh they could have filmed a regular
sized chessboard or used cgi to bring
the magical chessboard to life but why
not dream bigger the wizard's chess set
was designed by the production designer
stewart craig and the creative team made
these enormous pieces a reality as for
how they got around the board some
pieces were fully decked out with radio
control mechanisms to make the move
where and when they needed to oh and as
for the horse piece that explodes it was
set up with a compressed air device
inside it the coolest thing about it was
something when the pieces got smashed
because they actually exploded in real
life the morator's map looks just as
cool it's a 3d prop made with the help
of an illusionist one version was
actually constructed to be able to fold
itself
with tiny tiny threads that had to be
pulled in a certain order in a certain
way part of the reason they opted to
create some real magic was so its
existence came across as a realistic
item everyone where they are what
they're doing every minute of every day
brilliant normally large and
otherworldly creatures are dependent on
complex cgi but back in 2002 the chamber
of secrets went old school and built the
giant 18 foot wide aragog which features
hair made out of coconuts a cgi spider
would have resulted in much less
physical labor on set that's for sure it
took at least seven people to move the
three-quarter ton puppet that also used
aquatronics rupert grant who really does
have a fear of spiders was extremely
nervous on set but thanks to the
incredible puppet he grew more
comfortable with it simply because it
was so impressive the aragog big spider
which is horrible
the magical door of the chamber of
secrets moves so smoothly that it feels
like it would have to be cgi especially
considering the fact that it was made in
the early 2000s the special effects
supervising engineer created the door
from scratch making sure it worked in
real life just as they wanted it to in
the movie the basilisk is one of the
most terrifying magical beasts that
we've ever encountered in this film
while some shots of the basilisk are
done with cgi all the close-ups we see
are actually done with practical effects
a giant animatronic basilisk had to be
exact christopher columbus wanted
radcliffe to have a real creature to
work with he couldn't get the 25 foot
beast he'd requested but in the end the
animatronic head was able to move its
jaw and eyes had fangs that could
retract and the full head could even
slither thanks to some tracks
he was actually fighting a mechanical
version of that snake at times clearing
the leaky cauldron tables with cgi magic
could have been done easily enough but
the harry potter team had some tricks up
their sleeve literally
instead of just making glassware
disappear with the computer the actor on
set was doing live magic and sneakily
hid the props using sleight of hand
thinking outside the box is what you do
when bringing the world of harry potter
to life instead of resorting to editing
for creating the visuals of all the
spells the effects department got to
work setting up many wands and battery
packs so the actors could magically
light up their wands themselves even
without casting a spell while this was
effective radcliffe had a tough time
working with such a heavy prop since
these batteries were around the size of
a car battery the one chooses the wizard
mr potter the magical moment harry holds
the wand that chooses him was fully
created on set giving radcliffe a truly
incredible experience his amazement
wasn't just acting the addition of
lights wind and dust added to the magic
but if the film is slowed down it could
look like time was speeding up yeah i
really remember filming the devil's
snare
that was really fun the devil's snare in
the very first harry potter film
shockingly didn't resort to any cgi the
freaky plant was actually an enormous
puppet so when filming harry ron and
hermione struggling against it
puppeteers were controlling it while all
the vines were wrapped around the actors
and between takes all they had to do was
rearrange to film more then using one of
the simplest editing tricks in the book
reversing the film they produce the
effect we see
madame lestrange
if you will follow me the incredibly
complex vault doors and gringotts came
from the mind of the special effects
supervising engineer mark vollemore not
a detail was overlooked each of the
locks were actually made by hand shut
shut
up
aunt marge's balloon moment was so wild
to see on screen we can't imagine what
it would have looked like for the
filming crew or the actress who
experienced the real life inflation the
actress pam harris filmed the scene with
four different makeup looks and in a
bodysuit that could be pumped with air
in a shockingly realistic way it was
hours of effort on the actresses and
filming team's part but so worth the
final result one of the weirdest
weirdest things i've ever done in my
life the creepy and wild eye of mad eye
wasn't just a practically built prop it
was a radio-controlled eye the team felt
that maddie should have an eye that felt
like he could have created it and they
made it happen making sure the eye could
be controlled independently with the
radio control wrangling animals on set
is not an easy task especially on such a
large and already chaotic set however
wanting to bring as much realism to the
films as they could multiple animals
came together to film these animal
character parts four different owls
performed as hedwig over one dozen rats
took on the role of scabbers nine
neapolitan mastiffs appeared as fang and
crookshanks was actually four different
cats
very carefully introduce them to this
kind of environment it's so important
that you do that slowly
mrs weasley knows how to run a household
she was able to take care of her whole
family with the help of her self-working
cleaning cooking and crafting tools
all of these were center stage onset as
mechanical practical tools that could
take care of the needed effects floating
books exist in the wizarding world and
in the real world if you get some
special effects people wearing green
suits holding books out in the air with
their hands while cgi was done to remove
the hands those books were completely
real
it was a sensational shot when it comes
to the background in these magical
environments
the devil is in the details and with
such intricate rooms comes a lot of work
every single wand box we see and many of
which we don't see was made and labeled
no small task since there were 17 000
boxes in all of ander's shop the fact
that the night bus contains surprisingly
little cgi elements is a testament to
just how big the harry potter team
dreamed when it came to the world of
magic actual double-decker buses
provided the base of a triple decker
that had a third level welded together
even its wild speed was created manually
the initial filming saw the night bus
speeding around a bit while everyone
else moved around slowly and then they
changed the speed the film was played
back at to make the magic happen
considering just how much cgi there is
in the final harry potter films we'd
expect that tool to be used for the
fading of voldemort's robes but instead
the costume department was put to work
creating an array of faded robes to use
throughout the filming process it's a
raw hem on it not something i think you
can find anywhere else in the entire
harry potter films
this is not a drill the hogwarts express
is
and not just at a harry potter themed
exhibit the train we see in the movies
is called the jacobite express steam
train and is based in scotland a big
reason that the harry potter movies are
so magical is because of how much we see
was done in real life thanks to some
very creative minds which practical
effect were you most surprised by